la lettre était très attendue par moscou
mais la réponse n'est pas celle espérée
les états unis rejette formellement par
écrit l'une des principales exigences de
la russie il refuse de fermer la porte
de l'otan à l'ukraine
nous avons été clairs sur les sujets que
nous soutenons et défendons la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et son
intégrité territoriale ainsi que le
droit des états de choisir eux mêmes
leurs accords de défense et leur
alliance
anthony blinken assure toutefois offrir
une voie diplomatique sérieuse à la
russie et se dit prête à part lire à
nouveau avec son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov dans les prochains jours
même position du côté de l'alliance
atlantique qui elle aussi a envoyé une
réponse écrite à moscou
nous tendons à nouveau la main à la
russie pour tenter de poursuivre la voie
du dialogue et de trouver une solution
politique
à la frontière est de l'ukraine la
tension est extrême washington dit
s'attendre à une possible attaque des
forces russes d'ici la mi-février mais
en parallèle moscou et kiev se sont mis
d'accord mercredi pour préserver le
cessez le feu entre les séparatistes pro
russes et l'armée ukrainienne dans la
région du dombass les deux pays se
disent prêts à reprendre les
négociations dans deux semaines emmanuel
macron lui doit s'entretenir avec
vladimir poutine ce vendredi